this is what hard feels like take me
through that low Point there's actually
a story I'm getting a little Goosebumps
telling lip I was way back in my day
like you a party promoter but I was in a
fraternity and this was my first
semester being president we did this
huge party to like launch the new class
and the next morning they all wake up
and they're all hungover vomited in the
corner or whatever and we're like great
clean it up and they feel terrible and
they're like what the [__] this is what
I signed up for right two weeks of this
they get together they wanted me to meet
them because they want to meet on their
Turf I just asked them a couple
questions I was like who here before
pledging started was like I want to be a
part of this house me okay who here
thought it would be hard they raised
their hands I'm like guys this is what
hard feels like and then all of a sudden
it's like they got permission to feel
shitty and by getting permission to feel
shitty they stopped feeling a shitty